phase one he'll grab me please
and I will support his descent to check
my stability
phase one very static very static he's
gonna grab me
and I'll support his success
very excited
booms
he doesn't even need to know how to do a
break fall because I'm the one helping
him down
foreign
footwork
make sure you grab your nugget go
okay uh phase two more dynamic
but I'm still lowering him to check my
stability okay so it's not static like
this and I coming in
so I am using his motion
even if you guys
so I yield in boom
a yields in
[Music]
okay let's get
so phase three I'm going to do the same
yield I'm gonna come in but I'm gonna
move out for Mandarin once I get him
over I'm going to move out I'll I'll try
to assist his fall but it's a little
tougher to do so he's got to do some of
him
heels and stuff out
boom pop
so you can see
you
in
okay
amazing
foreign